[Music]  hello  I don't have a choice I gotta go okay  you got tagging listen that I say  something wrong tell me my family just  always wanted you to be strong for your  old man  position very few guys are forgetting  damn good deal are you kidding just  kidding  okay beautiful I caught up did you keep  of this gentleman let's see wins price  keeping their cool  Simon Says here put it down on the floor  my name is lieutenant aldo raine invite  each and every man under my command  those knees one puttered next scout and  I want my scouts you stand for the judge  gon hit me kill you  Oshin not fun I first sorry about taking  care of each other the best you can  what's wrong with taking care of  [Music]  what a day  this Joe ever-lovin that was just gone  war honor old I won't ask you do  anything I hadn't done myself  [Music]  that's the [ __ ]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]